why m23
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we faith I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from LA where I'm joined by the band
Papa Roach their forthcoming album
crooked Jesus set to release on may 19th
to hold you over they have the single
help streaming now and today the guys
who brought you the triple platinum
album infest are going to put their
money where their mouth is as we take on
the latest revolutionary food trend and
that's eating bugs guys welcome to first
we feet oh I thought it was going to be
cool with it this morning and then I
showed up and I'm looking at your scenes
in the jar I'm like I'm looking at
something that looks like I don't know
what it is it looks like okay a scorpion
yeah well apparently we're about to get
into that we are about to get into that
jolly but first let's go to Ali from
Bugaboo to figure out what the hell
we're going to be eating for lunch the
case for eating insects is incredibly
strong you thought blueberries or kale
or super foods insects logos out of the
water they have all nine essential amino
acids necessary for protein synthesis so
that's a complete protein they have less
fat they have less calories then the
same amount of protein would be from
beef for example my friends will often
say Ali there's a cockroach on the
ground with your lunch and like no bugs
there farm-raised they're braising the
same conditions of any other food source
that you eat so they're safe so when we
think about China or Mexico or Thailand
people they're commonly consumed in
sideshows nothing new in the past
several years it's become a lot more
mainstream especially in the United
States and 2013 the FAO and the UN
released a report and it spoke a little
bit about how in 2050 we'll have a
population of nine billion one of the
major issues facing us will be food
scarcity protein in particular and they
actually suggested edible insects as one
of the only viable solutions that we
know about right now to that crisis so
today for Sean and the guys from Papa
Roach I've prepared a little foray into
the world of edible insects I have a
good mix here of cricket and junebugs if
we get that by see some mealworms I have
a scorpion or two
just a little bit to really fill out the
products and then I have a fun game
lined up we're going to try a couple of
my favorite dishes some made with
insects some made out and we're going to
see if they can taste the difference
[Music]
all right so what Ally's done is she's
given us some raw ingredients so we're
just going to kind of work our way up
we're going to do some baby steps and
first our honey roasted crickets that we
got from Canada are we ready to try the
aka that it looks like a little pile of
weed look like a little Halloween
cinnamon all the buttons are breaking
the tie here we go okay here we're going
no hands two three pause easy how bad
those aren't bad so now we're going with
fire brimstone flavored mealworms you're
going in I'm going in all right here we
go oh man I'm so glad they're not moving
oh really to get it out the taste was
not too bad it's just the idea in my
mind of a worm now we have Chum polina's
from ento Vita this is a big dish in
Mexico there we go yeah this is the
first time that I've been not going to
be eating a bug it's just a meatiness of
it is it kidding you know what I'm
saying it's like a volume of it it's
just now I'm chewing on it it's like
buzz Durkins kind of up next we have the
land lobsters this is an armored tailed
scorpion it's been dehydrated and cooked
this thing's got sighs looks like this
isn't like just some little thing we're
going to and it's got a damn stinger on
the end that it's gonna you take that
off I'm not gonna eat this eat it eat it
you know a little sticky for the whole
thing go sticker sticker first no I got
you fat
we are in the bug zone yes we are in the
buff oh whoa what's that buttery nutty
oh I mean it's definitely unlike
anything else that's right yeah like you
said we're in the we're in the bug John
we've decided on this last round of hors
d'oeuvres that you can just pick
whatever you want I went with a June bug
because Allie said this is the realest
like if you really want the bug
experience you go with the June bug here
we are
oh I was like I thought it would be like
spring guts out of my mouth yeah me too
oh yeah yeah it's a [ __ ] that was the
real bear grill yeah dude we are not
stripes on that one tricycle I'll try it
I'll try the bamboo or maybe will to
help with the planter
whoa we're looking at Ella's village
right here did you like it if you take
that bamboo one all right yeah that's
the first time anyways now spit up yeah
there we go it's just there we go down
my mouth here's the deal right now we
just went in wasn't blind at all we knew
exactly what we were eating but now we
don't know what's on the dish we don't
know which one has insects we don't know
which one doesn't we're just going to
try for ourselves and maybe now with our
new discerning palate we can pick it out
but maybe we can't and that's kind of
the whole point here so we'll get a
couple dishes and we'll take it from
there you guys ready you're ready I'm
ready
[Music]
one of these breakfast burrito bites has
insects in it the other does not
Sean and Papa Roach are going to figure
out if we know which one
cheers fellas Cheers Oh for a bad bite
I'm good now I'm going to try the one on
the left
[Music]
this just looks like it has it broke
pretty okay so off the bat this isn't an
easy decision for me okay Joe let's not
let each other influence each other okay
if you think that the insect burrito is
on the right you hold up your right hand
on the left you hold up your left hand
does that sound good
that sounds good all right looking one
two three all right so it looks like we
have two rights three left
Alli I knew it I knew it
how do we all got it just like I said
it's like a half bugs but I couldn't
taste anything right so let's walk away
on this I feel like fellas you know
we've been around the block a couple
times we've all eaten crazy things
before but this is my first time with
insects as it was for you guys as well
what's our take away are we more likely
to try this or we was a better than we
thought it would be was it worse than we
thought we'd be let's get snap reaction
I would kid I think the crickets steezy
but there's some challenges in the
scorpion pretty much all the things we
tried I could see adding to you know a
meal grasshoppers are just too yeah
there's way too much to it you know I
mean or the June bug hell no yeah but
when maybe when they put it into
something like the sauce or like you
know nature's crouton there's crickets
yeah there you go
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so glad we didn't have to eat
cockroaches cuz I thought that you guys
yeah we're gonna throw the table over
and be like what are you doing to my
[ __ ] people yeah